it's 7 A.M at Sainsbury's and security
guards are about to fill up a cash point
machine
the robbers time their run they need to
attack the guards inside the Vault when
the cash boxes are opened
one guard is locked inside a robber
threatens to shoot the other and counts
down from 10.
a flying Squad detective explains what's
going on one of the guards has been held
in a headlock with a gun to his head
on this raid alone the robbers escaped
with more than a hundred thousand pounds
in other raids the robbers attacked
guards with guns hammers crowbars and
other weapons
for two years the gang prayed on cash
vans in and around London leaving few
Clues behind them they were well
organized they had a clear gang
structure they displayed a really good
tradecraft they were using stolen
vehicles clone number plates
displayed in knowledge of police tactics
I just played really good
anti-survedance techniques so that they
knew what they were doing that they were
they were you know a forcible gang when
the gang smashed open some boxes the
cash was sprayed with security die
difficult to spend
but in betting shops they found a way of
laundering the stained banknotes
ehabashui fed thousands into betting
machines he made one small bet and
stopped what he hadn't spent he was then
able to collect from the cash till
when the gang had too many stain notes
they burned them
two robbers were caught when they jumped
to red light
they were under surveillance and
arrested after a Chase
they were held in Wandsworth prison
before their trial the two of them
shared a cell and had a hidden mobile
phone police later discovered they used
it to coordinate more robberies by other
gang members who hadn't yet been caught
between them the robbers were jailed for
more than a hundred years
another suspect is still on the Run
Martin brunt Sky News